Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today is going to be all
about simulating evolution
on our computers. This can build virtual cars,
virtual creatures, even paint the Mona Lisa!
These all sound amazing, but,
evolution on a computer? How?
A few years ago, a really fun online app surfaced
that used a genetic algorithm to evolve the
morphology of a simple 2D car with the goal of
having it roll as far away from a starting point
as possible. A genetic algorithm? What is
that? Well, it is a super simple technique
where we start out from a set of random solutions,
and likely find out that none of them really work
well. However, we start combining and mutating,
or in other words, changing small parts of this
solution, until, oh yes! Something starts to
move. Now as soon at least one wheel is placed
correctly, the algorithm will recognize
that this one rolled so much further,
and keep the genes of this solution in the
pool to breed new, similar solutions from it.
A similar concept can also be used to design
the optimal morphology of a virtual creature
to make it skip forward faster. And,
look! That is so cool - over time,
the technique learns to more efficiently
navigate a flat terrain by redesigning its legs
that are now reminiscent of small springs
and uses them to skip its way forward.
And here comes something even cooler - if we
change the terrain, the design of an effective
agent also changes accordingly, and the super
interesting part here is that it came up with
an asymmetric design that is able to climb
stairs and travel uphill efficiently. Loving it!
And, in this new paper, scientists at Google Brain
tried to turbocharge an evolutionary algorithm
to be able to take a bunch of transparent
triangles, and get it to reorganize them so they
will paint the Mona Lisa for us. Or any image in
particular. The technique they are using is called
evolution strategies, and they say that it is
much faster at this than previous techniques.
Well, I will believe it when I see it. Hold
on to your papers, and let’s see together.
Here is a basic evolutionary algorithm after 10
thousand steps. Well, it is getting there, but
it’s not that great. And, let’s see how well their
new method does with the same amount of steps.
Wow. My goodness! That is so much better. In fact,
their 10 thousand steps is close to equivalent
to half a million steps with a previous algorithm.
And we are not done yet. Not even close. This
paper has two more amazing surprises. Surprise
number one. We can even combine it with OpenAI’s
technique called CLIP, this learns about pairs
of images and their captions describing these
images, which is an important part of DALL-E 2,
their amazing image generator AI. This
could take completely outlandish concepts
and create beautiful, photorealistic images out
of it that are often as good as we would expect
from a good human artist. Scholars holding
on to their papers, a cyberfrog, you name it.
So, get this, similarly to that, we can now
even write a piece of text, and the evolutionary
triangle builder will try to create an image
that fits this text description. With that,
we can request a triangle version of a
self-portrait, a human, and look at how similar
they are. Food for thought! But it can also try to
draw Walt Disney World, that is remarkable. Look
at how beautifully it boils it down to its essence
with as few as 200, or even just 25 triangles.
Loving it. Also, drawing the Google
headquarters? No problem at all.
And here comes surprise number
two. The authors claim that it is
even faster than a differentiable renderer.
These are really powerful optimization techniques
that can even grow this beautiful statue out of
nothing. And do all that in just a few steps. So,
claiming that it is even faster than
that? Well, that is very ambitious.
Let’s have a look. And…oh yes, as expected the
differentiable technique creates a beautiful image
very quickly. Now, try to beat that! Wow…the new
method converges to the final image even quicker.
That speed is simply stunning. Interestingly, they
also have different styles. The differentiable
renderer introduces textures that are not
present in the original image, while the new
technique uses large triangles to create a smooth
approximation of the background and the hair, and
uses smaller ones to get a better approximation
of the intricate details of the face. Loving it.
Now, let’s ramp up the challenge, and test
these a little more and add some prompts. And,
oh yes, this is why the differentiable
technique flounders on the prompts. Look.
It almost seems to try to do everything
all at once. While, the new technique
starts out from a fair approximation, and
converges to a great solution super quickly.
I hope that this new take on evolution
strategies will be plugged in to applications
where differentiable techniques do well,
and perhaps do even better. That would be
absolutely amazing because these are a treasure
trove of science-fiction like applications.
For instance, we would be able to
almost instantly solve this billiard
game, where we would like to hit the white
ball with just the right amount of force
and from the right direction, such that the
blue ball ends up close to the black spot. Or,
simulate ink with a checkerboard pattern, and
exert just the appropriate forces so that it
forms exactly the Yin-Yang symbol shortly after.
Or, here comes a previous, science-fiction like
example. This previous differentiable technique
adds carefully crafted ripples to the water,
to make sure that it ends up in a state that
distorts the image of the squirrel in a way that
a powerful and well-known neural network sees
it not as a squirrel, but as a goldfish. Wow.
And, if this new evolutionary
technique could do all of these tasks,
but better and faster? Sign me up
right now. What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!